على مدى العقدين الماضيين، قامت حماس
بتحسين قدرتها العسكرية ببطء، حيث قامت
ببناء صواريخ أكثر فتكًا وأطول مدى،
وحفر شبكة واسعة من الأنفاق
تحت تسليح وتدريب
المقاتلين الجهاديين في غزة بشكل أفضل من أي وقت مضى قبل أن تظهر
النتائج معًا
يوم السبت.  من
العداء بين إسرائيل وحماس على مر
السنين، كانت الدعاية الخادعة تشكل تهديدًا صارخًا
ونشرت حماس العام الماضي أسلحة
وتدريبًا على
الطائرات الشراعية الآلية، كما أظهرت
تخطيطًا دقيقًا للقتال في المناطق المبنية،
وكل ذلك فشل تاريخي
للمخابرات الإسرائيلية، ومقاطع فيديو حماس لبدء
هجومها.  تم نشر الهجمات من غزة
في غضون ساعات من إطلاقها،
جريئة في التنفيذ،
استهدفت حماس مواقع المدافع الرشاشة الإسرائيلية ومراكز
القيادة، ودمرت
الاتصالات العسكرية الإسرائيلية وشلت
القيادة والسيطرة، واجتاحوا
الأراضي الإسرائيلية وأطلقوا موجة من
الفظائع مما أسفر عن مقتل ما لا يقل عن 900 شخص.  تعرض الشعب
لأسوأ نكسة إسرائيلية منذ 50
عامًا، بمجرد فوز فرع من
جماعة الإخوان المسلمين، حماس، وهي حركة سنية، في
الانتخابات الفلسطينية عام 2006 على
أساس برنامج الإصلاح الاجتماعي ومقاومة
إسرائيل، الذي يمزقه الفساد وعدم
الكفاءة، وشن المنافسون
هجمات على الفور ضد الحركة
التي تنفي  حق إسرائيل في
الوجود على الإطلاق في النهاية، فازت حماس
بالسيطرة على
غزة وشددت قبضتها على القطاع الذي يسكنه
حوالي مليوني شخص، حيث
أغلقته إسرائيل ومصر إلى حد كبير مما
تسبب في مشاكل إنسانية حادة
ردت حماس بموجات من
الهجمات الصاروخية ضد إسرائيل والتي  ساءت الأمور
مع مرور السنوات من خلال
الهجمات المضادة التي شنتها إسرائيل من
الجو ومن خلال الهجمات البرية التي خلفت
الآلاف من القتلى وما زالت حماس تتولى زمام
الأمور، لكن نفوذ إيران كان مفتاح
القوة العسكرية لحماس، فقد
قام الإيرانيون بتدريب مهندسين فلسطينيين على
كيفية إنشاء تصنيع الصواريخ في
غزة.  نحن نعلم أن الإيرانيين قد قاموا
بتزويد بعض
معدات الإنتاج التي تحتاجها
لإنتاج صواريخ ذات دفع صلب
إلى غزة وإلى أماكن أخرى، وكذلك في
الماضي كانت عمليات التسلل تقتصر على
الهجمات من الأنفاق، وقد نجحت حماس في
إخفاء خططها الأكبر لعدة أشهر في
هذه الأثناء،  ركزت الحكومة اليمينية
جهودها على
العنف الفلسطيني المتزايد في
الضفة الغربية، وهناك اجتماعات مكثفة مع
فصائل المقاومة في غزة والضفة
الغربية ومع إخواننا في الخارج
حول إشعال تلك النار،
أخبرني المتحدث أيضًا أنه كان قد تم مؤخرًا
تدريب قوات في لبنان على الأرجح
إلى جانب حزب الله المدعوم من إيران.
المرحلة التالية التي خططت لها حماس وحلفاؤها
هي
الغزو البري الإسرائيلي الذي لا مفر منه تقريبًا، وكان آخرها في عام
2014 فوضويًا، وكان لدى حماس وقت طويل
للاستعداد لهذا النوع من
السيناريوهات بالضبط.  فرصة أن
تكشف حماس وحركة الجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطينية عن
قدرة جديدة يمكن أن يكون لها
تأثير هائل على
التوازن الاستراتيجي، كما تعلم إسرائيل أنه
يجب عليها قتال حماس على أراضيها في
المناطق الحضرية المليئة بالفخاخ المتفجرة
ومليئة بالأنفاق السرية والمنشآت.
ستستفيد حماس من تجربة
إيران في دعم حزب الله الذي دمر
درع إسراء رع في عام 2006، بينما تحاول
حماية حياة ما لا يقل عن 130
رهينة تقول حماس إنها ستقتلهم
إذا استمرت الهجمات الإسرائيلية في التعامل
مع الجماعات العنيفة المدعومة من إيران،
وهي دولة  عازمة على تدمير إسرائيل
وبناء سلاح نووي يمكن أن
يفعل ذلك بالضبط سام كايلي
سي إن إن